PETER-MARK VERWOERD: Hello, my
name is Peter-Mark Verwoerd.
I'm the head of
migration architecture
here at Google Cloud.
And what I'd like to
do today is talk to you
a little bit about ways you
can accelerate your migration
towards the cloud.
And what I'd like to
do is just to start off
by explaining how we
view IT applications
and where they
reside essentially
in the world of migration.
And so if you look
at this chart,
you can see that all
applications really
fall very broadly into these
four quadrants, whether they're
on the cloud or not, and
greater or lesser degrees
of modernization.
And so when we think about
where customers are going
and where customers would want
to be from the point of view
of the cloud
provider, we're hoping
that everyone would like
to be in that top quadrant
with the highlighted green area.
And we really think
that that's actually
the best location
for applications
to go-- where they're
the most efficient,
where they're secure, where
they have cost certainty
and cost efficiency.
And so we really do believe
that that's the best
place for applications to go.
However, we recognize
that, in reality,
most applications
actually reside
in that bottom left
quadrant where they still
sit inside of data centers.
They maybe haven't
been modernized.
They're using older
architectural patterns.
And they aren't,
say, de-coupled.
They aren't highly efficient,
and not containerized,
and so on.
And in reality, most
customer applications
actually do sit there today.
And so as a cloud provider,
what we have to do
is really come to where
customers are today.
And that's something that
Google Cloud has really
strived to do in the
last couple of years--
is not just, say, here's
this lofty goal of cloud
and we hope you guys get there.
But that actually we're
going to be providing tools,
and methods, and
best practices to be
able to go from this bottom
left to the top right.
And if you look at this
chart, really there
are essentially two
paths from the bottom
left to the top right.
Either you can move over,
and modernize applications,
and refactor them, and
so on, and leave them
inside the center, and
then move up to the cloud.
Or you can move up
from the data center
into the cloud with relatively
static applications that
don't change too much
in that transition.
And then slowly transition
them over to the right side
as you modernize, and refactor,
and rewrite applications.
And so we feel that both
of these routes are valid
and both of them have paths
of success that you could do.
However, today what
we're going to do
is focus on the path where
you go up and over first.
Because the reality is customers
and customer applications
are actually really
everywhere on this quadrant.
Very few people are sitting
in just one quadrant.
People have applications
in data centers,
moved applications out of
data centers into the cloud,
and moved them over
into the cloud.
They've modernized
inside the data center
and there's, generally
speaking, a very wide spread
of applications everywhere.
And so there are many, many
paths of success in migration.
And we're just going to
focus on, just for today,
on moving those applications
that sit in data centers
and moving them up into
the cloud as they are.
And so kind of an open
question to this audience here.
If you've ever worked on
a migration to the cloud
from, say, a data center,
what kind of challenges
did you have?
I'm sure there were many.
And so I, along with many
others here at Google Cloud who
have worked on other migrations,
sat down and brainstormed,
what were the top 10
challenges that we came across.
And we had a fairly
obvious trend that came up,
in that they were really cut
in half by technical challenges
and business challenges--
were really things that slowed
down acceleration and lowered
our chance of success.
So if we go through these
and we look at these business
challenges, these mostly
have to do with people,
and getting the right
people, and having
the right people biting into the
idea of a migration and really
see that it's going to be
successful for the company.
And these are the
kinds of problems
that really can't
be solved by running
a script, or an application,
or deploying some new version
of something or other.
This is really about
people believing
that the migration is the
best thing for the company
and that Google Cloud
is the best place to go.
And we've encountered
these sort of situations.
But these situations
that you encounter,
they really can slow
down your migration.
So if you look at things
like, in particular,
these first two bullets where
maybe management doesn't
believe 100% in the migration.
That can really impede
a lot of progress.
Or if people are
expecting the moon
and really you're
going into low orbit,
for example, that
can really slow down
the pace of the migration.
Or, in fact, when
different groups
have different ideas
of what exactly
the migration is
supposed to accomplish.
And so being clear about
what you're trying to do,
and who needs to be involved,
and who needs to support this
is so important for having
a successful migration.
And this is the kind of
thing that, as a provider,
we can do quite a bit to
help the people convince
senior management.
We can work with
different groups
across your company
to be able to describe
the benefits of
what a migration is
and what Google Cloud can do.
And there are also
several programs
that we offer from
different groups
within our company that actually
try to address these situations
upfront in a programmatic way.
But at the end of the day,
most of the business challenges
are really about people
rather than technical issues.
On the other hand, there
are always technical issues.
With any technical
project, of course
there are going to
be technical issues.
And we encounter these
frequently as well.
But it's important to recognize
them for what they are,
so you can start preventing
them from happening if you can
as you start on your
migration project,
so that you don't encounter
the issues that we've had.
Where we have had
migration projects really
slow down because some
things that maybe we
didn't foresee at the time.
So things like automation
really speed up migration
the more that you
invest in automation.
And so we've noticed
that across customers
that we've encountered, where
the more automated customers
are already, and the more of an
automation culture they have,
the easier the
migration becomes.
And the more that you can
do that before you migrate,
the easier your
migration will become.
And I think this second point
is actually probably one
of the more important ones.
We often get, say, the
opposite reaction of people
who are not enthusiastic.
We get people who are extremely
enthusiastic about migrating,
which is fantastic, but then
you come into a situation
where they want to do absolutely
everything all at once
and you get a bit of a
feature creep situation
where people just
want to add more,
and more, and more
to this product,
and it becomes untenable.
It becomes undoable.
And then instead
of actually doing
this grand ambitious
effort, actually it
gets all pulled back
into, in the worst case
scenario, nothing at all.
And so there has to
be some sort of limits
on what is realistic to do
in a particular time frame
and what needs to
be accomplished.
We've gone into customers that,
for example, had, say, a very
large MySQL back end database.
They were really
enthusiastic about, not only
moving to the cloud, but,
say, let's reconsider MySQL.
Maybe we should move to a
different kind of database.
Maybe we should move to managed
databases, like Cloud SQL.
Or we should try
a NoSQL database.
Maybe we could shard
out the data structure
into different
kinds of databases.
We had to caution them
against doing that
during the migration.
We said, look, we have
a specific timeline
to accomplish what you
need to accomplish here.
Let's get through that.
And then after
you're migrated, you
can reconsider
your design options
and look at your database
in a calmer atmosphere.
And once they did
that, they actually
saw the benefit of doing that.
And once the migration was
finished and was finished
successfully, then
they took the time
to actually examine
what were their database
needs in a way that didn't
impact the migration.
And they actually had a much
more reasoned conversation
among themselves
about how to migrate
that particular component.
And so it's really
important, if you've
got a big enthusiasm build
up, which is fantastic,
not to get too carried away.
And so these
technical challenges
are things that
we try to address
with technical
solutions, but they
are things that you want to
watch out for because they
really do slow down migrations.
And so when we look
at what slows down
or decelerates
migrations, we also
want to talk to you about what
would accelerate a migration.
And we think this is where
our best practices really
come into play.
And this is really what
we want to focus on
for the rest of this talk--
about what accelerates
your migration,
what moves it forward,
about what can help you.
And so these are best
practices, again,
gathered from
different coworkers
that I have and myself on
the actual best practices
that we have learned from
working with customers.
So this is something that
is practical experience
that we have seen actually
doing the act of the migrating.
And so I think the
most important one,
and this is what we're going
to spend most of the time on,
is building a proper
cloud foundation.
And we're going to
go into that in quite
a bit more detail, so I'm
going to leave that for now.
While you're building
your cloud foundation
and throughout your migration,
the next most important thing
to do is actually think about
security the whole time.
So this is not something
that you think about
at the beginning.
This is not something you
think about at the end.
This is part of every
single step of a migration.
Otherwise it's really
just not going to work.
You're going to have
either people complaining,
or you're going to have
things that are not secure,
or, worst of both worlds,
you're going to have both.
And so it's very important
to make that a consideration
while you do your entire
migration the whole time.
As I said before, automation
can really improve a migration.
The more that you can do it,
the faster and easier it can be.
It's the difference between
having to manually copy, say,
an entire application or
maybe an entire operating
system from one
location to another,
verifying that the copy happened
correctly, copying over data,
making sure the tests run,
making sure the application is
connected the same way.
Versus just saying,
no, I'm going
to redeploy this application
from one location to another.
You're talking about the
difference between hours
versus minutes, or even
days versus minutes,
the more you can automate.
And so everything you
can do to automate
your infrastructure
in your environments
is only going to help.
Fourth, the more you
can prepare for change
and the more you can
slice up your migration
into manageable chunks,
the easier it will be.
So if you can build iteratively
on your migration plan,
if you can say these steps
are going to happen, and then
build on those steps, and
just be prepared for one step
to influence another step in
a way that you didn't expect,
you're going to be much better
suited and better prepared
for success.
Rather than having
one, two, three steps,
maybe have like one through 20,
one through 50, whatever it is,
smaller, more manageable steps.
And that way you can adjust
as you go along, as you're
making this migration.
Perhaps this is the first
time you've done this
and you really need to
watch what you're doing,
and how you're getting
there, and how it's moving,
so you really don't want to
be too rigid in your plan.
So be prepared for change and
it will work out pretty well.
And then finally,
once you're migrated,
you're not really done.
That's just the first step of
actually existing on the cloud
and having an application there.
So really you need to prepare
for what we call day two.
So day one is this migration.
Day two is this application now
exists in a new environment.
It needs to be managed.
You need to monitor it.
You need to log it.
You need to audit it, redeploy
new versions, and so on.
So you need to prepare
to manually operate
this-- not manually.
But you need to actually
operate this application
as it exists in the cloud.
So you need to prepare
for that as you migrate.
Now, I said I was
going to go back
to what a cloud foundation
is and how important this is
in terms of the best practice.
And so we're going to dive
into that a little bit more.
And so creating a
cloud foundation
is really about creating
the location where
your applications are going
to migrate before you migrate
a single application.
And the reason this
is so important
is that, if you can
properly migrate
into an already created, an
already vetted, an already
secure, or already properly
built out foundation,
it's going to make the
migration significantly easier.
Rather than trying to do that as
you migrate your applications,
very much kind of like trying
to build a plane while you're
trying to fly the plane.
You really want to have
this foundation set
before the first
migration happens.
And then once that
migration happens,
you don't have to think
about all these parts
of the foundation that exist.
You can just keep on migrating
applications and learning
what's unique about
your application,
about your company,
about your setup,
rather than having to figure out
what is unique about this cloud
environment that
you're moving to,
which is really what you're
figuring out when you establish
your cloud foundation.
So if we look at
the first one, this
is not, say, rocket science.
This kind of makes sense that
the first thing you should do
is pick the first application
that you want to move.
But picking that application
can be very difficult
and it can be non-intuitive,
or maybe perhaps
not even obvious if you
haven't done this before.
So the characteristics
of, say, a good mover
is something that is not going
to bring the business down
if it doesn't work.
On the other hand,
it can't be so far
out of the relevancy
of the business
that it's not going to be
important if it does move.
So you want things
that are still
a working application of
business application, something
that matters.
It's not a POC.
It's not just a
throwaway application.
It is something
real, but it is not
something that is going
to break your business.
But you still have
to learn from it.
You still have to have some sort
of knowledge gained from it.
And also, you have to
be able to control it.
So if it's a license
that you don't control,
if there's particular
hardware or software that
connects to it that
you can't control,
that's not something
that's going
to make a good first mover.
And if you look at the
technical characteristics,
they're similar in theme.
You don't want
something that's so
tied to the rest of the business
from a technical standpoint
that it's going to
be hard to untangle.
You don't want
something that's so
intertwined with
software licenses,
it's going to be
difficult to move.
You want something that
can cleanly move on its own
as easily as
possible, rather than
something that's
really wound up inside
of many, many other things.
And so if we look at, say,
an example application
where we have users and
external applications connecting
to a website and a
mobile application.
And there's a log in system.
There's blog posts, and so on.
Some sort of, say, customer
commentary system, for example.
It could be a lot of things.
And if we look at this
whole system, what
would be a good first mover?
For example, this
mobile application
doesn't really depend on much
of the rest of the application
stack.
It's got pretty simple
inputs and outputs
and it can be pulled out and
put in a different application
location fairly easily.
And so this would make a pretty
good example of a first mover.
On the other hand,
bad first movers
are pretty much the
opposite of everything else
we suggested-- things
that are deeply
entangled with the rest
of the application stack;
licenses that don't lend
themselves to being migrated;
things that are either far too
business critical to move first
or things that are so irrelevant
that they don't really
prove anything; edge
cases that are, again,
so far out there that they're
not going to be relevant
for the rest of your
application base
don't particularly
make good first movers.
And so if we look, again, at
the same application stack,
this blog post pool that sits
in the middle of everything
would be really
difficult to move first.
It's got so many connections
to everything else,
so many dependencies on data
in upstream and downstream
systems, it would just be
so much more challenging
than picking a
different application.
So it would be a much
more difficult application
to move first.
Next, you want to establish
an identity on the cloud.
So people are going
to be using your cloud
environment-- your users, your
developers, operations, and so
on.
You need to establish
who those people are,
and how they are
going to get access,
and what those
identities actually mean.
And as far as Google
Cloud is concerned,
we have different identities,
which are either people,
they're groups, or
they're service accounts,
so they are automated systems
acting in certain ways.
And they would become roles.
And those roles have permission
to act on certain services.
And so you've got a great deal
of granularity and flexibility
in how you want to
set that up in order
to do pretty much anything
you need to do in the cloud.
And so if you look at
the types of identities
that we have in
the cloud, you've
got actual people,
human accounts,
versus service accounts,
which are not human.
Those are robotic accounts,
automated accounts,
however you would
like to describe them.
You have groups and
then, finally, domains.
And these are all
the different ways
that identity comes
together in the cloud.
And the really key
thing here that I
would like you to
take away from this
is that there are a couple
of ways of setting this up.
And we try to be as
flexible as we can in order
to meet you where you are.
If you don't have a
current identity system,
then you can set
that up in the cloud
and set that up
with Google Cloud.
Or if you already
have an existing one,
then you can synchronize
that with the cloud.
And so that maintains your
existing identity structure.
But the point is that we want
to meet you with what you need
and what you have today.
Third, organizing your
resources is critical.
So once you have decided
what is going to move,
you've decided who
are your people
and what are their roles
going to be in the cloud,
deciding how you're
going to organize
your cloud is very important.
In Google Cloud, you can have
an organization with a number
of folders underneath it.
Within these folders,
you can add projects.
And the projects actually
hold the resources-- things
like virtual machines,
databases, queues, and so on.
And so there's a layering of
organization that you can add.
And how you decide
to do this really
depends on your
organizational preferences.
I mean, we have a number
of ideas and suggestions,
but it's really going
to depend on what
suits your company best.
So if we take a look at,
say, maybe the simplest
way of organizing a company,
you have an organization
at the top.
Then you have folders for
environments, and then
applications underneath.
The great thing about this
is it's fairly simple.
It's intuitive.
It does not get
complicated very soon.
On the downside,
this is not something
that lends itself to flexibility
if you have environments
that don't quite fit in here.
If you have things
like shared services,
you have no knowledge of
the different divisions
within a company.
So if you take a slightly
more complicated view,
you could say, let's organize
at a second level by function.
So you have applications,
and you have shared services.
and then underneath, a
relatively similar structure.
And so the downside
is you're getting
a little more complicated.
The upside is you've got
a little more flexibility
in terms of adding
shared services,
recognizing that there
are different functions
of applications, and
so you can add that.
And then finally, if
we look at, say, maybe
the most complex recommendation
that we start with,
you're actually
dividing up applications
by division before you get down
to function or environment.
And the upside of this is you
get fantastic flexibility.
You can really define and
describe your organization
in Google Cloud
the way it actually
is reflected in reality.
The downside is that it is much
more complicated to manage.
It's much more complicated even
to visualize and conceptualize.
And crossing different
project barriers
and different folder
barriers may, in fact,
be more difficult.
But it's all going
to depend on the plus and
minus of what you want
and what works best for you.
And so there are different
ways of doing that.
We're capable of supporting
whatever those are,
but it's important for you to
decide what works best for you.
Next, once you have this
foundation created--
so you've selected your
first mover already,
you've decided who
your people are
going to be when they're
in the cloud, decided
what that organization
is going to look like.
And then next, you actually
need to group those individuals
and resources
together so that you
can figure out who's going to
do what, when, how, to whomever.
So this is an example
grouping that we
could recommend for groups
starting out in the cloud.
In the first one,
you want to have
a group that's going
to define and control
how your organization
is defined,
and what permissions you're
going to give to everyone,
where is everyone going to go?
At the top level,
what are the things
that you're going
to decide to do?
And so this group is only
going to decide what things are
and what things can be
within the organization.
Ideally, they're going to
decide very little else.
So you want to have
separation of duties
as clearly as possible.
Next, you could have a
network administration group.
And this group,
as you may assume,
is going to define
how the network works.
They're going to define
what kind of networks
you're going to use, where
are the firewalls, who's
going to have access
to what, how are you
going to make connections
between different projects,
different networks, cloud
to data center, and so on.
And they're going
to decide that.
And once again,
you're going to want
to have a narrow focus
on that, so that is all
that that group is
responsible for.
Same idea with
security, where you're
going to have security
administrator group define what
is permissible for the
different roles, what
is permissible with the
different networks, what
is permissible, say,
from a virtual machine.
And that that is the sole focus
of what they are going to do.
And then finally, actually
a very common grouping,
is actually billing.
So people who are responsible
for how the company gets
billed, how the individual
divisions within the company
are going to get chargeback
based on the total cloud bill
and so on.
And that is their sole focus.
And that is a set of permissions
that you can sequester off
from everything else,
where they're only
looking at how the bills come
in, where they're coming from,
who is charging what, and
who is spending so much.
And these are
really just getting
started recommendations.
There is a lot more flexibility
and a lot more granularity
that you could add
over time, but these
are strong recommendations
that we have upfront.
And then finally, the last step
of building out this foundation
is really defining your network.
So you have a first mover, you
have people and identities,
you have an
organization structure,
you have groupings for
permissions, and roles,
and responsibilities.
And finally, you
need to really define
the network that these
applications are going
to live in, and what
your network wants to be
and what you need it
to be for your company
and for your
applications to succeed.
So the first thing
you need to decide
is how you're going
to connect to Google.
So if you have existing
infrastructure already,
you're going to have
to pick some kind
of connectivity option
upfront, whether that's
going over the public
internet, whether that's going
over carrier peering,
so partnering with some
of our partners to be able
to lease lines over carriers,
or directly peering
with Google ourselves.
And so these options are
all available to you.
They have greater or lesser
degrees of cost and speed,
so it really depends
on what you need
and how long you need it for.
None of these options
have to last forever.
So something you
could start with going
over the public
internet, creating a VPN.
Or you can move to direct
peering over time and then
scale that back down.
It really depends
on what you need
and how long you need it for.
So if you look at some of
these different options.
If you look at, say, going
over the public internet
and peering at an ISP, if you
look on the left hand side
here, you've got an
SLA between yourself
and the peering
equipment at the ISP.
And you've got
capacity management
between the ISP and the
Google peering location.
Meanwhile, if you
do direct peering,
you're actually directly peering
with Google at an exchange
room in a data center,
or something like that,
in the peering location with us.
And so you're cutting out
actually a lot more steps
in between.
And you've got more
direct connectivity.
You can pay for
higher bandwidth to be
able to enable that as well.
And once you've got
connectivity to Google,
you've got to decide,
what is your network going
to look like?
What regions are
you going to use?
Are you going to be
localized to, say, a region
that's closest to you?
Are you going to use
multiple regions?
Are you going to
use all regions?
Google networks span
all regions by default.
And so you've got to decide,
in terms of operations,
where are you going to choose
to deploy applications,
or where are you going to choose
to deploy virtual machines?
And how do you connect
these different networks,
if you have multiple network?
So the strategy we've seen for
many, many years has been a hub
and spoke, where at the hub
you've got shared services,
and in the spokes you've got
the different applications,
different environments that
can connect into the shared
services and still have
separation of concerns
out in the spokes, where you're
connecting between the hub
and spoke over a VPN, or if
you're doing a network peering.
Google has also introduced what
we call shared VPC networks,
where you have a single VPC,
a single network that is, say,
administered by the network
administration group.
And other projects
have permission
to launch resources within
specific subnets in that group,
inside that network.
And so this is a different way
of doing shared services that
doesn't involve peering.
It doesn't involve VPNs--
if you need to have
shared services,
if you need to have still
separation of concern
and separation of ownership
of resources, but you want
applications still deployed
within the same network.
And so we've seen customers
have a lot of success with this.
And so that's the end
of my recommendations.
That's the end of the five
steps of the cloud foundation.
Again, these are built out over
time and experience of what
we have done with customers.
But we strongly recommend
that really building out
that foundation is going to
lead you to so much more success
and actually have a
better chance of moving
your migrations
forward more quickly
by doing this, for lack of a
better term, homework up front.
If you've really built that out,
if you take the time to invest
in what this needs
to be, then you're
going to have a great
deal of more success.
So thank you.
And we're going
to have questions
in just a few minutes,
so please stick around.
Hello.
Welcome back.
Thank you for these questions.
I'm sure there are plenty more.
What we'll try to do afterwards
is get to those questions
and answer them offline.
But we've selected
six here that seem
to touch on a few similar
concepts and questions.
So I'm going to go through
those and hopefully answer
what you've asked me here.
This first question--
what open source tools
can help with automation?
There are a lot.
And it really depends on
what point in your deployment
pipeline you're talking about.
But you have everything
from right at the beginning
to right at the very end.
So I'm going to run
through just a few.
So if you look at
software that helps you
with your continuous
integration side of things,
you've got a lot of things
that plug into Jenkins.
So Jenkins is really
a fantastic controller
for that side of
the pipeline where
you're integrating different
points of deployments; code
that's committed to Git or
wherever you keep your code;
and being able to
package that up,
being able to run integration
tests, unit tests, whatever
those are, and then
deploying that out as well.
And integrating along
that side from Jenkins
into something like, say, using
configuration tools, like Chef,
and Puppet, and so on, really
actually make it fairly
easy to have a situation where
you have a developer that
can commit to a shared
repository for whatever
project.
Jenkins knows that new
things have come in,
can run integration tests, and
then deploy that via, say, Chef
or whatever you would like to
use, and be able to deploy that
onto virtual machines.
And you can integrate
all that with, say,
a cloud native
environment configuration
tool like Deployment Manager
or an open source equivalent,
something like
Terraform, where you've
got Terraform or
Deployment Manager managing
the actual resources and
something like Chef and Puppet
managing the configuration
of your applications
on those resources.
If you want to use
containers, then certainly
things like Kubernetes,
which is open source--
it was created at Google, but
it is definitely open source--
is a great container
management orchestration tool.
It seems to be fairly
popular these days.
And so if you are
using containers,
then you want to have a
container orchestration
to also manage that.
Second question--
how to encourage
a culture of automation
to accelerate migration?
That's actually a
fantastic question.
I actually firmly believe that
automation is one of the best
ways to accelerate migration.
And so this is really important.
I think one of the
things to do is
to sell IT and
development on the idea
that automation doesn't
just help migration.
It helps developers, no matter
where they're deploying to.
It helps IT.
It helps operations.
It helps security
because you can basically
take all these steps
that are potentially
manual at this point
and codify them.
You can put them into
code and commit them.
You can audit them.
You can look at them.
You can see what the processes
are, what the procedures are,
to be able to improve them, to
be able to see what is actually
done.
And you're taking all
this operational overhead
off of people who are
doing this manually.
And so there are huge benefits
well beyond migration.
And one of the other nice
things about automation
is actually it's not an
all or nothing proposition.
You don't go from a completely
manually deployed pipeline
to a fully automated
one in one step.
There's baby steps you can
take all along the way.
And these incremental baby
steps have huge benefits
at every single step.
If all you want to do is move
to automated configuration
management with
Ansible, then do that
and you will see huge benefits.
Even if you're not
fully automated
further up the
pipeline, you're still
going to get a lot of benefit.
Or from the other
side, if you just
want to implement Jenkins
so that every time you
commit to your
repository you're running
some tests, that has huge
benefits right there already.
And so I think the two
pronged approach towards going
to a culture of
automation is one,
everyone needs to understand
that this is not just
for migration.
It benefits day to day
operations of all of IT.
And two, baby steps
are hugely beneficial.
And you don't have
to do all or nothing
to be able to really
benefit from automation.
Third question.
What is the best way to get
started with a migration?
I think you've got
to have a reason.
So why do you want to move?
If you're in a data center,
are you capacity constrained?
Are you not happy with
your current equipment?
Is upgrading the equipment
going to be too expensive?
Are you at the end of a lease?
Is there a reason why wherever
you are currently deployed
is not working?
Because that's often a
great motivating factor.
On the other hand,
is there something
in particular about moving
to Google Cloud that
is particularly enticing?
Is there something
very interesting
about machine learning or using
Kubernetes on Google Cloud that
is particularly enticing?
So I think getting a good reason
for why you want to migrate
is absolutely important.
And so once you
have that reason,
this is the thing that overcomes
those business challenges
that I was talking
about earlier--
About motivating
people and getting
people convinced
that this is the best
thing to do for your company
is the best way to get started.
So really finding that
motivating reason,
and getting out there,
and pushing people
to be able to start
that migration
is a good way to start.
Next question.
What resources are available
from Google and Google's
partners to assist
with our migration?
So I'll speak about us first.
We have tools that
are available,
things like data transfer tools.
So you can send us data offline.
You can use data transfer
tools to transfer data
from wherever it sits
into Google Cloud storage.
You can work with
us on VM migration
where we have a
VM migration tool.
We also have, like
I said, programs.
So things like, if you work with
our professional services team,
they have several
migration programs
that can help you move forward.
And so those are the
defined specifically
for migration tools that
you can use from us.
In addition to that, working
with Google account teams
and so on will certainly
enable those migrations.
They'll help you
out in whatever way
and connect you into the
various different groups
at Google that can
help you with that.
In terms of our
partners, we have
a lot of technical partners,
like CloudEndure or Velostrata,
that are all geared towards
automating migrations
and migration tooling.
Attunity works on
data migration.
So we have a few of those.
We work with large partners
that will come in and assist you
in terms of human resources.
Moving your applications,
moving your data.
And we partner with
a lot of those.
And so you can go everywhere
from looking at our resources
online, and reading
up documentation,
to implementing our
tools, working with us,
working with partners, or any
kind of combination thereof.
We do that fairly frequently.
I've done that many, many
times myself-- everything
from only working with Googlers,
to only working with partners,
and, like I said,
everything in between.
Question five.
Does the shared
VPC project apply
to both public and
private subnets?
For private subnets,
what's the model
for accessing the resource?
So the first question, yeah.
In a shared VPC, you can make
public and private subnets.
It's really very much dependent
on what sort of shared VPC
you want.
It's under the control of the
admin for that shared VPC.
If you want all of the
subnets it to be private,
you can do that.
If you what none of them, some
sort of mix, you can do that.
For private subnets,
what's the model
for accessing the resource?
I'm not entirely sure
I get the question,
but I'll try to answer.
The way shared VPCs work is
that there is a project that
owns the VPC, the shared VPC,
and it gives permission out
to other projects to launch
resources within that VPC,
within a subnet.
And so if you've decided
that this subnet is going
to be a private subnet and
that project A has permission
to launch resources, launch
VMs within that subnet,
it's going to be able to
have total control over that.
And then the network admin, so
the admin of the shared VPC,
is going to determine how the
different subnets are allowed
to interact with each other.
Whether they're going to
be totally firewalled off,
whether they're going to have
some access between each other,
or if it's going to
be completely open,
it's going to be determined
by that network admin.
And then finally, I guess
this is kind of related,
please clarify the shared
VPC networks so you
can touch on that once more.
So, like I said, a
shared VPC is a VPC
owned by a particular project.
It's administered by
a particular project.
The idea being though
that project is not going
to launch any resources itself.
It is a way to collect
network administration
within a single project
and be able to distribute
that network out to
different projects
that it can then
launch resources.
And so the scenario
that this is built for,
and we've seen this with
quite a few customers,
is that network
administrators need to control
what happens in the network.
But development teams
are relatively autonomous
and own the resources
that they deploy.
And so when the development
team deploys resources,
they want to be able to own
that, and be able to control
that, and be able to say,
this is what we want to do,
and this is not what we want
to do, with our resources.
But also we don't want to
administer our own network.
We want the network admin team
to be able to handle that.
We just want to be able to
control our own resources.
And so that is kind of the goal
and the idealized situation
of what a shared
VPC is used for.
There are actually a lot
more use cases for that.
In particular, for
shared services
is where it comes up a lot.
But the case being
most of the time
it's when teams own the
resources, when they
own the applications, when
they own the services that
are deployed, but do not
want to or should not
own the actual network
administration,
is really what it's geared for.
And that is it
for our questions.
And so thank you very much.
Thank you for joining me.
And the next session
is coming up shortly.
Thank you very much.